this was all that was left when Flight
mh17 with 298 people aboard was blown
out of the sky above Ukraine destroyed
by a missile
debris spread over many miles nobody
survived this
most of the victims were Dutch but 10
were British
the attack came just months after Russia
had invaded Crimea the missile was fired
from Russian hell territory
today a Dutch Court concluded that these
three men two Russians and a Ukrainian
were guilty of mass murder
foreign
the memory of that attack remains potent
belongings and bodies mingled the plane
broken to Pieces an act of Destruction
that has caused profound pain
this is a Act of barbarism that has been
take place and I never can put it behind
me it's always in your back and I called
it a stone in my heart and Stones
disappear don't disappear
but today a sense of conclusion if not
closure well this troll was held here at
skipol airport in Amsterdam symbolically
because this was the last place where
all the victims stood before they
boarded mh17 the flight that was to end
all of their lives
there were life sentences for the three
men convicted all of whom had close ties
to the Kremlin I mean that's a summary
of today Russian Federation is totally
responsible for for killing it's one of
98 people that's without a shell over
that
so this verdict is a reminder that
Russian aggression in Ukraine dates back
eight years not eight months Adam Parson
Sky News Amsterdam